I I have a lot of respect for anybody
that has a lot of uh uh respect for his
Heritage for his whatever Faith he is
family last name anybody that
contributed towards him I have a lot of
respect for people like that I don't
have to agree with you politically but I
sit there and I say you know what great
by the way Bernie Sanders okay here's a
guy that is a socialist okay here's a
guy that politically him and I are on
complete opposite ends politically when
it comes down to most issues
economically but you know what I do
respect I respect the fact that he is a
True Believer of what he believes in
it's not an act that's really who he is
and the election year it's unfortunate
that uh Hillary Clinton and others
pushed him out because there should have
really been Bernie Sanders versus Trump
and quite frankly I would have loved
that because it would have been the best
debate of socialism versus capitalism
and the world needed to see that we
missed out on that opportunity so